Salut Romain, bien les vacances ? On a pas le temps !
[explosion]
Salut ! Eh oui, pour nous aussi c'est la rentrée.
Ouiiiiiiiiiii!
Bon en vrai DTC ne s'est pas arrêté cet été, mais je suis quand même parti un petit peu en vacances,
comme en témoigne ce bronzage scandaleux
Alors qui dit rentrée dit: vidéo de rentrée !
L'année derniere, j'ai eu 90 ans le temps d'une journée,
j'ai flotté tout nu dans le noir,
je me suis mis en slip par moins 150 degrés,
je me suis fait tatouer la fesse,
je me suis fait détatouer la fesse !
Enfin...
Et j'ai transformé Romain en pénis !
Tu le fais hyper bien !
Bref, on a testé plein de trucs et on a très envie de continuer.
Alors si vous avez des idées, si vous avez envie que je teste quelque chose en particulier,
dites le dans les commentaires
L'année dernière j'ai aussi rencontré plein de gens très cool qui avait plein de choses très intéressantes à raconter et là encore, ça va continuer,
et là encore, si vous avez des idées...
L'année dernière, on a aussi parlé de pleins de sujets très différents:
je suis allé à des conventions où j'ai rencontré certaines et certains d'entre vous, et notamment très très récemment au festival Frames à Avignon
*foule en délire*
C'était génial, vous m'avez donné plein d'idées pour la nouvelle saison, on va essayer de faire encore mieux que les précédentes.
Donc cette année en plus des formats que vous connaissez déjà,
on va essayer de développer des nouveaux formats et vous allez sûrement aussi pouvoir me voir en dehors de DTC,
mais ça, je vais pas en parler pour l'instant.
Donc vous avez compris, la saison 3 de DTC ça sera plus que jamais avec vous, donc là, chez vous, dans les commentaires,
dites moi tout ce qui vous a plu dans les précédentes, tout ce qui vous a pas plu, tout ce que vous avez envie de voir dans la nouvelle !
On se retrouve dès la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo, elle est déjà tournée, elle est formidable !
D'ici là, mettez vous bien et surtout, portez vous bien !
*explosion*
Ça va être speed cette année...